a congressional panel led by democrats
has been investigating the january 6th
riot
now after conducting nearly a thousand
interviews and collecting 250 terabytes
of data the panel will finally begin to
reveal its findings to the public trump
was prepared to seize the presidency and
likely to invoke the insurrection act
and declare martial law so we're going
to tell the whole story of everything
that happened
thursday will be the first of several
public hearings they'll feature live
witnesses and previously unseen videos
from january 6. i think
people would want to see some new
information
and particularly new striking
information about trump's involvement
videotaped depositions of trump's
daughter and son-in-law may be shown at
the hearings but trump himself is not
expected to testify we fight like hell
and if you don't fight like hell you're
not going to have a country anymore
last year he was impeached for inciting
insurrection but was not convicted among
the answers that may be revealed what
trump was doing as his supporters
stormed the capitol and why he waited
three hours to call them off you have to
go home now
we have to have peace trump has not
faced criminal charges whether that
changes after these public hearings is
uncertain
the hearings will also delve further
into security failures in the days ahead
of january 6 and efforts by trump and
his aides to overturn the election
january 6 was a very dark day in
america's history i think it's important
to have a full accounting of what
happened
and making sure that through these
hearings
we ensure that it doesn't happen again
republicans call the democrat-led
investigation a sham a recent nbc news
poll shows the percentage of americans
who believe trump was responsible for
the riot has dropped to 45 percent and
it's unclear how many people will tune
into this round of hearings but
democrats are hoping for another chance
at a public reckoning
that may help the party in november's
midterm elections
heidi jo castro al jazeera washington